So we are driving around Los Angeles at the best time of day, 5.41 p.m. Vivian Leigh works with me at 99% Invisible, and she's on her way out for after-work drinks at one of her favorite bars in L.A. And my husband, Cody, is driving us. I'd like to say, because I'm recording, but you're driving me because what? Because you're a passenger princess. That's exactly correct. Some people enjoy driving. Some people like Vivian really do not. But nobody enjoys being stuck in traffic.
所以我们在一天中最美好的时间——下午 5:41，在洛杉矶到处开车兜风。Vivian Leigh 在 99% Invisible 和我一起工作，她正准备下班去洛杉矶她最喜欢的一家酒吧喝一杯。我的丈夫科迪（Cody）在开车。我想说，因为我在录音，但你其实是在给我当司机，因为什么？因为你是乘客公主。完全正确。有些人喜欢开车。有些人像 Vivian 一样，真的很讨厌开车。但没有人喜欢被堵在路上。
No one's moving. What are they doing? I want to burn the intersection of the ground and piss on the ashes. Oh, my God. L.A. is famously a car town, known for its endless freeways and its soul-crushing rush hour traffic. And in a city full of bad intersections, Vivian and Cody are headed towards one that many consider to be the worst. It's where three roads, Fairfax, Olympic, and San Vicente all intersect.
一动不动。他们在干什么？我想把这个路口烧成平地，并在灰烬上撒尿。天哪。洛杉矶以汽车之城闻名，拥有无尽的高速公路和令人心力交瘁的高峰期交通。在这个充斥着糟糕路口城市里，Vivian 和科迪正驶向一个许多人认为是全城最糟糕的路口。三条道路——费尔法克斯大道（Fairfax）、奥林匹克大道（Olympic）和圣维森特大道（San Vicente）在这里交汇。
I think it's technically called the Fairfax asterisk, but I like to think of it as the Devil's Three Way, because you have this weird triangle in the middle, and there are like one, two, three, four, five traffic lights. To navigate this intersection, Vivian and Cody have to make it through two traffic lights in quick success. only a couple hundred feet apart. Oh, God. Caught right in the middle of... Oh, no. We are stuck in the middle.
我想它在技术上被称为费尔法克斯星号路口，但我喜欢把它叫做魔鬼三岔口，因为中间有一个奇怪的三角形，而且大概有一、二、三、四个、五个红绿灯。为了通过这个路口，Vivian 和科迪必须在短短几百英尺的距离内连续通过两个红绿灯。哦，天哪。正好被夹在中间……哦，不。我们被卡在中间了。
They make it through one traffic light, but then get stopped at the next one. And now they're stuck right in the middle of the triangle. Oh, God. So there are... Oh, God. We're... Oh, boy. We are in between...
他们通过了一个红绿灯，但在下一个红绿灯又被拦下了。现在他们被死死卡在这个三角形的正中央。哦，天哪。所以有……哦，天哪。我们……哦，天哪。我们在……之间。
Oh, my God. I'm Delaney Hall, and this is Service Request, from 99% Invisible and Campside Media. We rarely think about infrastructure until it breaks, and then suddenly it is all we can think about. So every week, we're diving into your burning questions about the invisible systems all around us. We're exploring how infrastructure works and how it's designed and maintained. Today, traffic lights in L.A. We're looking at the system behind them, meeting the people who decide when they flip from one color to another,
天哪。我是德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall），这里是由 99% Invisible 和 Campside Media 联合制作的《服务请求》（Service Request）。我们很少去思考基础设施，直到它坏掉，而突然之间，它成了我们唯一会去想的事情。因此，每周我们都会深入探讨你们关于身边的隐形系统的迫切疑问。我们将探索基础设施是如何运作的，以及它是如何设计和维护的。今天的主题是洛杉矶的红绿灯。我们将探究其背后的系统，结识那些决定红绿灯何时变色的人，
and trying to answer the question on every L.A. driver's mind. Why is this red light so damn long? Oh, you son of a bitch. The roots of L.A.'s modern traffic system go back to 1984, when the city was preparing to host the Olympic Games. L.A. was expecting more than a million visitors and thousands of athletes. Traffic in L.A. was bad, and all these people would be, flooding into a city that was already pretty maxed out.
并试图回答所有洛杉矶司机心中的疑问。为什么这个红灯这么该死地漫长？哦，你这个混蛋。洛杉矶现代交通系统的根源可以追溯到 1984 年，当时这座城市正准备举办奥运会。洛杉矶预计将迎来超过一百万名游客和数千名运动员。洛杉矶的交通本就很糟，而所有人都会涌入一个本就已经不堪重负的城市。
City leaders were worried that athletes and spectators wouldn't be able to make it to their events. You're going to the 1984 Olympics in Los Angeles. And some of your friends are asking you questions. Aren't those freeways congested? Can you find your way around? What about the smog? At this time, all of the traffic lights in L.A. operated independently from each other.
城市领导者们担心运动员和观众无法及时赶到比赛现场。你要去洛杉矶参加 1984 年奥运会。你的一些朋友会问你一些问题。那些高速公路不是很拥堵吗？你能找到路吗？雾霾怎么办？当时，洛杉矶所有的红绿灯都是各自独立运作的。
Each one had a timing mechanism that would flip the light from green to yellow to red on a regular cadence. If a traffic light broke, or if an intersection got extra congested, engineers would likely find out about it from angry phone calls. And then someone from the city would have to drive out to that intersection to manually reprogram the timing mechanism of the traffic light. In the process, they would often get stuck. stuck in the same congestion they were trying to fix. But the Olympics gave city engineers the motivation and the funding to try something new. With the games looming, a transportation official named Ed Rowey assembled a small team and they started tinkering.
每个红绿灯都有一个定时机制，按照固定的节奏将绿灯切换为黄灯，再切换为红灯。如果红绿灯坏了，或者某个路口变得格外拥堵，工程师们通常会通过愤怒的投诉电话得知这一情况。然后，市里的某个人必须开车去那个路口，手动重新编程红绿灯的定时机制。在这个过程中，他们经常会陷入他们试图去解决的同一场拥堵之中。但奥运会为城市工程师提供了尝试新事物的动力和资金。随着奥运会的临近，一位名叫埃德·罗维（Ed Rowey）的交通官员组建了一个小团队，他们开始进行摸索改良。
And what they came up with was a network that connected 118 traffic lights around the L.A. Coliseum into a single system. For the first time, instead of sending someone out to every congested intersection, engineers could see what was happening across a whole area and then adjust signal timing remotely in real time. The system went online just before the game started. It was an experiment and it worked. This is Salida Reynolds. She's the chief innovation officer at LA Metro, and for eight years she ran LA's traffic light system,
他们想出的方案是一个将洛杉矶纪念体育场（Los Angeles Coliseum）周围 118 个红绿灯连接成一个单一系统的网络。这是历史上第一次，工程师们不再需要派人前往每一个拥堵的路口，而是能够实时查看整个区域的情况，并远程调整信号灯的定时。该系统在奥运会开始前夕上线。这是一个实验，而且成功了。这位是萨利达·雷诺兹（Salida Reynolds）。她是洛杉矶大都会交通局（LA Metro）的首席创新官，她曾管理洛杉矶的红绿灯系统长达八年，
trying to make traffic a little bit better in one of the most traffic-y cities in the world. There are a lot of other really interesting things that happened during the 84 games to make it such a success. But if you ask anybody who was here at the time, they will say, wow, they really solved traffic. The first full day of Olympic competition saw a few hurdles on the massive L.A. freeway system. The games not only avoided gridlock, but the sea breeze is also cooperated. And sort of famously, when the games were over, the mayor at the time, Tom Bradley, at the closing sort of press conference said, the games are over, let the traffic begin. So, you know, there was this sort of feeling that everybody had kind of made it work for the period of the games. And now we were going to be back to our old ways.
试图在这个世界上交通状况最糟糕的城市之一，让交通变得稍微好一点。84年奥运会期间还发生了很多其他非常有趣的事情，才使得它取得了如此巨大的成功。但如果你问当时在这里的任何人，他们都会说，哇，他们真的解决了交通问题。奥运会正式比赛的第一天，庞大的洛杉矶高速公路系统确实遇到了一些小波折。奥运会不仅避免了交通大瘫痪，海风也十分配合。而且众所周知，奥运会结束时，当时的市长汤姆·布拉德利（Tom Bradley）在闭幕记者会上说：“奥运会结束了，让交通开始吧。”所以，你知道，当时有一种感觉，大家在奥运会期间都设法让系统运转了起来。而现在我们要回到老路子上了。
It reminds me a little of the extraordinary measures you hear every city taking, like Beijing, five. firing particulate into the air to make the smog, like, rain away before the crowds came for the Olympics. So it's interesting to me that in many ways it was one of these extraordinary measures that was taken to try to solve a problem temporarily for the Olympics. But then it, then it continued. Why did it continue? I think the engineers at the time were very excited by the improvements that they had seen. And they were real and measurable. They had reduced people's delay by about 30, 35 percent, which in turn improved emissions, right, because you didn't have as many people idling, because you were just moving the most efficient way possible.
这让我想起你听说每个城市都会采取的那些非凡举措，比如北京在奥运会观众到来之前，发射颗粒物到空中让人工降雨，以驱散雾霾。所以我觉得很有意思的是，在许多方面，这也是为了在奥运会期间临时解决问题而采取的非凡举措之一。但后来，它却延续了下来。为什么它会延续下来？我认为当时的工程师对他们所看到的改善感到非常兴奋。这些改善是真实且可度量的。他们将人们的延误时间减少了大约 30%、35%，这反过来又减少了尾气排放，因为你不会有那么多车在 idling（怠速等待），因为你只是在以最高效的方式通行。
L.A.'s success with traffic during the Olympics made a big impact. Cities planning future Olympics called them for advice. And in the years that followed, officials from Salt Lake City and Sydney and Beijing, all wanted to study what LA's transit leaders had built. As the system continued to expand, it got even more sophisticated, with new high-tech tools that could sense the conditions on the roads and then respond automatically. Los Angeles is now trying to unsnarl its traffic by applying some very advanced technology. The city has begun to plant electronic sensors beneath major downtown intersections. Those sensors determine the speed and density of traffic and feed that information to a computer beneath City Hall.
洛杉矶在奥运会期间的交通成功产生了巨大的影响。规划未来奥运会的城市纷纷打电话向他们讨教经验。在随后的几年里，来自盐湖城、悉尼和北京的官员都想研究洛杉矶交通领导者们所构建的系统。随着系统的不断扩展，它变得更加精妙，拥有了能够感知道路状况并自动做出反应的全新高科技工具。洛杉矶现在正试图通过应用一些非常先进的技术来解开其交通乱麻。该市已经开始在市中心主要路口下方铺设电子传感器。这些传感器可以测定交通的速度和密度，并将这些信息传输给市政厅下方的计算机。
The computer analyzes the information and automatically operates traffic lights to relieve congestion and speed up traffic flow. We reduced delay at intersections by about 20%. We reduced stops by 35%. By the way, that last voice was Ed Rowey, who died in 2023. When we come back, we'll learn about how LA's traffic system has grown since the Olympics. and why it is now known as the eighth wonder of the transportation world. That's after the break. Since 1984, the small, scrappy system that started with the Olympics has grown into one of the most sophisticated traffic management operations in the world.
计算机分析这些信息并自动操作交通信号灯，以缓解拥堵并加快交通流量。我们将路口的延误时间减少了约 20%。我们将停车次数减少了 35%。顺便说一句，刚刚那个声音是埃德·罗维（Ed Rowey），他于 2023 年去世。稍后回来，我们将了解洛杉矶的交通系统自奥运会以来是如何发展的，以及为什么它现在被称为交通世界的第八大奇迹。广告之后见。自 1984 年以来，这个以奥运会为起点的、规模虽小却充满拼劲的系统，已经发展成为世界上最先进的交通管理运营机构之一。
Today, it's known as AtSAC, Advanced Transportation System and Coordination, and it controls almost all of the city's 5,000 traffic signals. And while it would be malpracticed to say that the system has solved LA's traffic issues, it has made traffic a little less bad. Believe it or not, without this system, the streets of L.A. would be even more clogged. The way it works is that there are sensors buried in the pavement at most intersections across the city, and they count cars as they pass. The sensors feed a constant stream of data back to a control room in downtown L.A., where end up in downtown L.A., where, engineers can watch a live map of LA traffic. When a street starts to back up, the system automatically responds.
今天，它被称为 ATSAC（先进交通系统与协调系统），控制着该市近 5,000 个交通信号灯中的几乎全部。虽然说该系统已经解决了洛杉矶的交通问题未免有些言过其实，但它确实让交通状况没那么糟糕了。信不信由你，如果没有这个系统，洛杉矶的街道将会堵塞得更加严重。它的运作方式是，在该市大多数路口的柏油路面下埋设传感器，当汽车驶过时，它们会对车辆进行计数。传感器将源源不断的数据流输送回洛杉矶市中心的控制室，在洛杉矶市中心的控制室里，工程师们可以实时观察洛杉矶交通的动态地图。当某条街道开始出现拥堵时，系统会自动做出反应。
It can extend a green light or make one shorter, nudging timing across the whole system of intersections to help traffic flow more smoothly. And there are traffic engineers, transportation engineers, and planners and other folks that are sitting in an office in downtown Los Angeles. They have hundreds of cameras that give them basically a lot of cameras. that give them basically a 360-degree view of the city at any time. And they also have a landscape view of what's happening with every single transportation signal at all of the 5,000-plus intersections that they're monitoring at any given time.
它可以延长绿灯时间或缩短绿灯时间，微调整个路口系统的定时，以帮助交通更顺畅地流动。洛杉矶市中心的一间办公室里坐着交通工程师、运输工程师、规划师以及其他工作人员。他们拥有数百个摄像头，基本上可以提供大量的摄像头，随时让他们能够对城市进行 360 度的全景观察。他们还可以从宏观视角了解在他们随时监控的 5,000 多个路口中，每一个交通信号灯正在发生的情况。
So these various signals run into ATSAC, which I am imagining as sort of the NASA Mission Control Center. Is that what it looks like? Kind of, yes. Houston, we have our truck. It is number one, two, eight. Celina told me the AtSack Control Room has become legendary among traffic nerds, and it's been featured in a couple of movies,
因此，这些各种信号汇入 ATSAC，我在脑海中将其想象为某种类似于美国宇航局任务控制中心（NASA Mission Control Center）的地方。是那个样子的吗？某种程度上，是的。休斯顿，我们有卡车了。编号是 128。萨利达告诉我，ATSAC 控制室在交通极客中已经成了传奇，它曾出现在几部电影中，
including a 2003 heist film called The Italian Job. We're moving out. There's this scene where someone hacks into the AtSack system to create a huge traffic jam in the middle of L.A. We've crashed. It's not a crime. Crash. We've got power. I can't log in.
包括 2003 年的一部劫盗电影《偷天换日》（The Italian Job）。我们要撤了。有一个场景是有人黑入了 ATSAC 系统，在洛杉矶市中心制造了一场大堵车。我们死机了。这不是犯罪。死机。我们有电源。我登录不上去了。
And there's a shot of the AtSat control room in the movie, with engineers holding their heads in their hands, staring at these enormous screens that show intersections across the city. They're totally freaking out as cars smash into each other, and traffic descends into chaos. So in that control room, you're saying it's a mix of technology and human intervention. to make the signals change.
电影中有一个 ATSAC 控制室的镜头，工程师们双手抱头，盯着那些显示着全市各个路口的巨型屏幕。当汽车相撞、交通陷入混乱时，他们彻底抓狂了。所以在这个控制室里，你是说这是技术和人工干预的结合，用来改变信号灯吗？
So in some cases, there's a person pressing buttons, flipping switches, and making the lights change? They can do that in extraordinary circumstances. So when I first got to Los Angeles, there was actually a giant sinkhole that opened up in the ground over by UCLA. Less dramatic than that. There's spontaneous protests or other things happening. At that point, they're making decisions about, okay, we're going to leave this. light on green for longer and clear people out of a space when they need to be redirected or rerouted.
所以在某些情况下，有人在按按钮、扳动开关、让灯光改变？他们在非常时期可以做到这一点。因此，当我刚来到洛杉矶时，加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）附近实际上裂开了一个巨大的天坑。比那还要不戏剧化一些。有自发的抗议活动或其他事情发生。在那种情况下，他们会做出决定，好吧，我们要把这个信号灯的绿灯时间延长更久，在需要引导或改道时，把人们从一个空间疏散出去。
But these are mostly extraordinary circumstances. For the most part, it sounds like there are computers that are making decisions about when to flip from green to yellow. Yeah. Think about the way that we're managing movement through a city. You know, we're managing it in space and time. And the space is limited, right? We have 7,500 miles of streets in the city of Los Angeles, so there's a lot, but we have what we have.
但这通常都是非常时期。在大多数情况下，听起来好像都是由计算机在决定何时从绿灯切换到黄灯。是的。想想我们管理城市中交通流动的方式。你知道，我们在空间和时间上对其进行管理。而空间是有限的，对吧？洛杉矶市有 7,500 英里长的街道，所以有很多，但我们拥有多少就是多少。
It's fixed. So that congestion that you experience, that's too much demand for a fixed amount of space. I like this idea that traffic engineering is all about space and time, because it elevates what seems like a mundane discipline into something a little more epic. The space part is pretty simple. Basically, every car, bus, bicycle, and pedestrian is competing for the same fixed space on the roads. And the reality is that engineers cannot do much to expand that space. But they can work with time. And that's where their special algorithms come in.
它是固定的。所以你体验到的拥堵，就是对固定数量空间的需求过剩。我喜欢这种观点，即交通工程完全关乎空间和时间，因为它将一个看似平凡的学科提升到了一种更具史诗感的境界。空间部分很简单。基本上，每一辆汽车、公交车、自行车和行人都在争夺道路上相同的固定空间。现实情况是，工程师们在扩大空间方面做不了太多事情。但他们可以利用时间。这就是他们特殊的算法发挥作用的地方。
There is so much data collected from those sensors embedded in the pavement. And it reveals stuff like rush hour patterns. patterns and holiday surges and what a Wednesday on the road looks like versus a Sunday. And the algorithms crunch through all that information and then translate it into precisely timed traffic lights. For the most part, those algorithmic sort of calculations for how much green time one street gets versus the other and that balancing, it's pretty fixed by the time of day and the day of the week and so on and so forth.
从那些嵌入路面地下的传感器中收集了大量的数据。它揭示了诸如高峰期模式、节假日出行高峰、周三的道路情况与周日有何不同等信息。算法会对所有这些信息进行大量运算，然后将其转化为定时精确的交通信号灯。在大多数情况下，这些关于一条街道获得多少绿灯时间与另一条街道相比以及这种平衡的算法计算，根据一天中的时间和星期几等因素，基本上是固定下来的。
there are moments when unpredictable things happen and the sensors have a certain amount of intelligence and they're able to perceive those changes and reallocate things in real time. And then sometimes the system becomes so strained that it breaks and you have to have a human in the loop to intervene and actually manage it manually. And that human needs to be connected to all of the other humans that are there to make things work. But to move this many cars and this large of a system that has this much complexity and variation, you have to have all of those things at the same time. That sounds like this increasingly sort of brain-breaking math problem, like how you synchronize across that many signals
有时会出现不可预测的情况，传感器具有一定数量的智能，它们能够感知这些变化并实时重新分配资源。有时系统承受的压力太大而崩溃，你就必须让身处系统中的人进行干预并进行实际的手动管理。而这个人需要与那里所有其他人保持联系，才能让事情正常运转。但要让这么多的汽车、如此庞大且具有如此大复杂性和变化的系统运转起来，你必须同时具备所有这些要素。这听起来像是一个越来越让人头疼的数学问题，比如如何在这么多的信号灯之间进行同步，
and how you make this intersection flow smoothly without creating key. And how you make this intersection flow smoothly without creating chaos in an intersection somewhere else. That sounds so hard. It is. And it's also, we're talking about people's lives, right? That's one of the reasons why people love transportation is because it has such an immediate effect on people's lives. And so part of what you're also doing is trying to figure out the tolerance that exists across the system for delay or frustration.
以及如何让这个路口顺畅通行，而又不会在其他某个路口造成混乱。这听起来太难了。确实如此。而且这也是在谈论人们的生活，对吧？这就是人们热爱交通的原因之一，因为它对人们的生活有着如此直接的影响。所以你正在做的事情的一部分，也是试图找出整个系统对延误或挫折的容忍度。
And so you're having to sort of consider how pain is being spread around and you're having to sort of accept that in order to balance things, everybody has to share the pain a little bit. And you're also making a judgment call. So on the main drag, there may be, let's say, 45 or 50,000 people a day that are driving on that main street. on the cross streets, you have a much smaller number of people. And so you're going to privilege the greatest good for the greatest number, right? You're going to privilege the 50,000 people on the main line, and the people on the side streets are going to experience more pain because they're going to have to wait a little bit longer.
因此，你必须考虑到痛苦是如何被分摊的，你还必须接受为了平衡各方，每个人都必须分担一点痛苦。你也在做一个权衡决策。所以在主干道上，比如说，每天可能有 45,000 或 50,000 人在那条主干道上开车；在横街上，人数要少得多。所以你要把最大多数人的最大利益放在首位，对吧？你要优先考虑主干道上的 50,000 人，而小路上的居民则会经历更多的痛苦，因为他们必须多等待一会儿。
But eventually you're going to get to go. Right. What I hear you saying is that it's collective and there's also something a bit utilitarian about it. Yeah. And that goes for everybody who's using the street, right, people biking and walking as well. If there's a bus, right, that's coming along or a train that needs to make it across the street, there's a lot more people moving much more efficiently in the train or on the bus or even on a bike, taking up a lot less space, which again is one of our most precious resources.
但最终你还是会通行的。没错。我听到你说的是，这既是集体性的，也有点功利主义的色彩。是的。这适用于所有使用街道的人，对吧，骑自行车和步行的人也是如此。如果有公交车正驶来，或者有火车需要穿过街道，火车上或公交车上，甚至自行车上有更多的人在更高效地移动，占用更少的空间，而空间再次成为我们最宝贵的资源之一。
And so figuring out how to balance safety, efficiency, delay. and the sort of quality of people's lives are all the ingredients that have to go into the creativity with which the system gets managed. Yeah, it's interesting to think about this as it's this highly engineered system. There's algorithms. There's lights. There's wires. But ultimately, it is about people's time. It's actually very human. It is. I consider it as much of an art as it is a science. You know, when we move a little white line on the street, you know, six inches this way or six inches that way, we know that it changes how fast people drive or how they behave. And so it's a lot more about human behavior than it is about a math equation. Yeah, exactly.
因此，弄清楚如何平衡安全性、效率、延误以及人们的生活质量，这些都是必须融入系统管理创造力之中的所有成分。是的，把这视为一个高度工程化的系统很有意思。有算法，有灯光，有电线。但归根结底，它关乎人们的时间。这其实非常人性化。确实如此。我认为它既是一门科学，也是一门艺术。你知道，当我们把街上的一条小白线向这边移动六英寸或向那边移动六英寸时，我们知道这会改变人们开车速度或他们的行为方式。所以它更多地关乎人类行为，而不是一个数学方程式。是的，完全正确。
When we come back, 99PI producer Vivian Lay visits the AtSack control room. Once she's there, she hacks into the system and screws up traffic across L.A. in order to facilitate the movement of a huge amount of stolen gold. Just kidding. She just wants to figure out what's up with her least favorite intersection, the Fairfax asterisk. That's when we return. Hi, good morning. The Atzac control room is located in downtown L.A.
稍后回来，99PI 制作人 Vivian Lay 将参观 ATSAC 控制室。到了那里，她将黑入系统，搞砸洛杉矶各地的交通，以便运送大量被盗的黄金。开玩笑的。她只是想弄清楚她最讨厌的路口——费尔法克斯星号路口究竟是怎么回事。我们稍后回来。嗨，早上好。ATSAC 控制室位于洛杉矶市中心，
in a huge glass building around the corner from City Hall. It's a big space that looks kind of like a corporate meeting room with blue-gray carpet and a wall of glass windows where you can see traffic down below. But the main attraction is the huge block of screens that stretches across the front of the room. It displays live camera feeds of intersections across the city so that engineers can keep an eye on where congestion is building up and why it's building up. The camera show me why it's congested. This is Eric Zambon. a transportation engineer in charge of the Atzac Center. He gave Vivian a tour last month and talked her through the big screen
在市政厅拐角处的一栋巨大玻璃建筑里。这是一个很大的空间，看起来有点像一个公司会议室，铺着蓝灰色地毯，有一面玻璃窗墙，从那里可以看到下方川流不息的交通。但最大的亮点是横跨房间正面的一大块屏幕。它展示了全市各个路口的实时摄像头画面，以便工程师能够密切关注拥堵在哪里加剧以及加剧的原因。摄像头向我展示了为什么会拥堵。这位是埃里克·赞邦（Eric Zambon）。他是负责 ATSAC 中心的交通工程师。上个月他带 Vivian 参观并向她介绍了大屏幕，
and what it allows the engineers to see. Is there an emergency vehicle that's blocking a lane causing congestion, or is there even a crash in the middle of the intersection? And at that point, we jump on our system, and we would modify signal timing parameters to best help people get around those locations. Gotcha. On that same big screen, there's also a map of every traffic signal in L.A.
以及它让工程师们能够看到什么。是否有紧急车辆挡住了车道导致拥堵，或者路口中央是否发生了车祸？在那种情况下，我们会启动我们的系统，并修改信号灯计时参数，以最好地帮助人们绕过这些地点。明白了。在同一个大屏幕上，还有一张洛杉矶所有交通信号灯的地图。
They show up as multicolored dots of light. So that's the graphic of all the traffic signals. Every dot is a node or a traffic signal, and that's our signal network. This shows in real time the status of the signals in the city. Every color represents something to us, and although it just looks like a Christmas tree to some people, it tells us the operation of the signals just at quick glance. We're looking at, you know, the layout of Los Angeles, mostly green. Could you explain to me like what patterns you see?
它们显示为多色的小光点。这就是所有交通信号灯的图表。每个点都是一个节点或一个交通信号灯，这就是我们的信号网络。这实时显示了该市信号灯的状态。每种颜色对我们来说都代表着某种含义，虽然对某些人来说它看起来只是一棵圣诞树，但只需一眼，它就能告诉我们信号灯的运行状况。我们正在看，你知道的，洛杉矶的布局，大部分是绿色的。你能向我解释一下你看到了什么规律吗？
When you look at this, what does this actually mean to you? Okay, so green means it's online, good communication. It's running a cycle length. Right now we're coming up on just past the AM peak traffic period. All right, so things are starting to slow down. As Eric explained, most of the traffic lights were working well, and they were running their usual timing. As the cars start to congest,
当你看到这个时，这实际上对你意味着什么？好的，绿色意味着它是在线的，通讯良好。它正在运行一个周期长度。现在我们刚刚过了早高峰交通期。好的，所以情况开始放慢速度了。正如埃里克所解释的那样，大多数红绿灯都运转良好，并且在按常规时间运行。随着汽车开始拥堵，
it ramps up the green time to help provide throughput to get people through that area. So these are the smartest. The ones with the pink in the middle are the smartest intersections that we operate. Could I ask you about one intersection in particular that really grinds my gears?
它会增加绿灯时间，以帮助提供通行能力，让人们通过该区域。所以这些是最聪明的。中间有粉红色标记的是我们运营的最聪明的路口。我能问一下关于一个让我特别抓狂的路口的问题吗？
Of course. Are you from L.A.? I am from L.A. It's pretty close to me. Do you know what the Fairfax asterisk is? If that's Olympic Fairfax San Vicente. Yeah. Yeah. So that was designed well before we had our current.
当然。你是洛杉矶人吗？我是洛杉矶人。它离我很近。你知道费尔法克斯星号路口吗？如果那是 Olympic Fairfax San Vicente。对。对。所以那是远在我们拥有当前的……之前设计出来的。
Eyeballs. Yes. It's so bad and there's nothing I can do about that. We've viewed that through the lens of 50, 60 years of traffic. We have put that into traffic signal modeling software. We've done everything we can. I hate to say this, but the confluence of three major streets during peak hours leads to nothing but frustration and signal timing can't fix it. And we just inherited that very bizarre,
眼光。是的。它太糟糕了，我对此无能为力。我们是通过 50、60 年的交通视角来看待这一点的。我们已经把它输入到了交通信号建模软件中。我们已经尽了所能。我很遗憾这么说，但在高峰时段，三条主要街道的汇流只会带来沮丧，而信号灯定时也无法解决这个问题。我们只是继承了这个非常怪异的、
geometrically bizarre intersection that has terrific signals and we have to assign right away two different streets going east-west and one going north-south. And it's proven to be a very difficult thing. I don't know that it'll get better. Do you feel like you have to kind of just do what you can with like the mess that you've been giving. That's exactly how I feel. Yeah. Yeah. I'm only laughing because you describe what goes on in my mind every day. It's that space time problem again, as Salita Reynolds described it. The AtSack system has improved traffic in L.A., but it can't control the fundamental layout of the streets or the number of people using them. It can't control the fact that L.A. was...
几何形状怪异的路口，它有极好的信号灯，我们必须将东西走向的两条不同街道和南北走向的一条街道的路权分配好。事实证明这是一件非常困难的事情。我不知道它是否会变好。你是否觉得你只能勉强应付你所接手的这个烂摊子。这正是我心里的感受。是的。是的。我笑只是因为你描述了每天在我脑海中发生的事情。正如萨利达·雷诺兹所描述的那样，这又是那个时空问题。ATSAC 系统改善了洛杉矶的交通，但它无法控制街道的基本布局或使用它们的人数。它无法控制洛杉矶被……
built as one of the most car-centric cities in the world. Engineers can play with time, coaxing millions of people through various bottlenecks. But sometimes, no matter how advance their algorithms, it's still kind of lipstick on a pig. And they're still left with something like the Fairfax Asterisk, an intersection that just was not designed to handle so many cars. So I just want to understand sort of how much what we've learned about AtSAC might apply to another city. So if someone's sitting at a red light in another city, you know, Des Moines, Miami, how much of what's happening is basically the same and how much is really unique to the Atzac system itself? A lot of other cities will have maybe part of the city on a connected traffic management.
建成世界上最以汽车为中心的城市之一的事实。工程师们可以利用时间，诱导数百万车辆通过各种瓶颈路段。但有时，无论他们的算法多么先进，这仍然有点像是“给猪涂口红”（徒劳无功）。他们仍然得面对像费尔法克斯星号路口这样根本就不是为了应付这么多汽车而设计的路口。所以我只是想了解一下，我们在 ATSAC 上学到的东西在多大程度上可以应用于另一个城市。因此，如果有人坐在另一个城市的红灯前，比如得梅因、迈阿密，其中发生的事情有多少基本上是相同的，又有多少是 ATSAC 系统本身真正独有的？许多其他城市可能将城市的某一部分连接到交通管理系统上，
system and most other major metropolitan areas will have a centralized traffic management center where they'll be the same kind of setup. There'll be some cameras, there'll be some video, but it's usually for some subset of their city, some smaller, you know, maybe it's the downtown and it's a sort of a smaller scale kind of place where things are being managed. And so it is a repeatable sort of blueprint that has become kind of state of the practice. Okay. And then finally, another Olympics are coming. It's 44 years after Atzac was born. Is it going to play a similar role this time around? Is it going to expand again? Yes, absolutely. It's going to play a similar role. And we have some more tricks up our sleeve in terms of what does Atsac 3.0 look like for the 28 games. And how can we make sure that we're moving the trains and the buses and keeping people on foot safe? and getting around by bike or scooter, one of the most fun and attractive ways to do so.
而大多数其他主要大都市区都会有一个集中的交通管理中心，那里会有相同的设置。会有一些摄像头，会有一些视频，但它通常只针对他们城市的一部分，某个规模较小的地方，比如市中心，是一个进行管理的小型场所。所以这是一个可复制的蓝图，已经成为一种行业实践标准。好的。最后，又一届奥运会要来了。这是 ATSAC 诞生 44 年之后。这次它会扮演类似的角色吗？它会再次扩张吗？是的，绝对会的。它将扮演类似的角色。而且在 28 年奥运会的 ATSAC 3.0 会是什么样方面，我们还有一些绝招。以及我们如何确保能够运行火车和公交车，并保证行人的安全，
Well, thank you so much, Salita. It was really fun to learn about this system. We really appreciate having you on. Yeah, my pleasure. We're about to go through the intersection. Back at that terrible intersection, Vivian and Cody are waiting. We're just sitting under red light, so this might be a lot of dead air for a while. Someone's crossing the intersection on roller blades.
通过骑自行车或滑板车出行，这是最有趣、最具吸引力的方式之一。好的，非常感谢萨利达。了解这个系统真的很有趣。非常感谢你能来。是的，我的荣幸。我们正要穿过这个路口。回到那个糟糕的路口，Vivian 和科迪正在等待。我们只是坐在红灯下面，所以这可能会有一段时间的空白期。有人正踩着轮滑鞋过马路。
Are that crazy? In the dark, too. In the dark? But pretty soon, the light changes, and they start to move. Okay, we are turning left on. Fairfax. Here we go. Oh, green lights.
这太疯狂了吧？天黑了还这样。在黑暗中？但很快，灯光变了，他们开始移动。好的，我们要左转上 Fairfax。我们走吧。哦，绿灯。
All the way. All right, that's it. Not so bad, right? That wasn't so bad. Not the worst traffic we've ever been in. We started with the question, how do LA's traffic lights actually work? And the answer is that the whole city is wired up. There are sensors embedded in the pavement at many traffic lights,
一路绿灯。好吧，就这样。没那么糟，对吧？没那么糟糕。不是我们遇到过的最糟糕的交通状况。我们以这个问题开始：洛杉矶的红绿灯实际上是如何工作的？答案是整个城市都联网了。许多红绿灯的路面下都嵌入了传感器，
and they connect through miles of underground fiber optic cables to a centralized control room. In that control room, engineers monitor traffic flow and make adjustments in real time. It's a system that started very small. when Ed Rowey and his team faced this impossible task, which was to keep traffic moving smoothly during the 1984 Olympic Games. And since then, the system has grown, and Atzac now manages nearly 5,000 traffic lights at intersections across the city. With that, consider the service request resolved.
它们通过数英里的地下光纤电缆连接到一个集中的控制室。在那个控制室里，工程师们监控交通流量并实时进行调整。这个系统起步非常小，当时埃德·罗维和他的团队面临着这个不可能完成的任务，即在 1984 年奥运会期间保持交通畅通。从那时起，该系统不断发展，ATSAC 现在管理着全市路口近 5,000 个红绿灯。至此，服务请求视为解决。
Today on the show, you heard Salita Reynolds, the chief innovation officer at L.A. Metro, and Eric Zambon, a transportation engineer in charge of the Atzac Traffic Management Center for L.A.D.O.T. You also heard Vivian Lay, supervising producer at 99PI and her husband, Cody Franklin. We're going to go to our pub now. Yeah. Bye. What infrastructure mystery keeps you up at night? Is there something in your life that you use every day, but you don't actually understand?
今天的节目中，你听到了洛杉矶大都会交通局首席创新官萨利达·雷诺兹，以及洛杉矶交通局（L.A.D.O.T.）ATSAC 交通管理中心负责人、交通工程师埃里克·赞邦的发言。你还听到了 99PI 监督制作人 Vivian Lay 以及她的丈夫科迪·弗兰克林（Cody Franklin）。我们要去我们的酒吧了。再见。什么样 Infrastructures（基础设施）的谜团让你夜不能寐？生活中是否有这样一样东西：你每天都在使用，却并不真正理解
how it works, submit your service request by recording a voice memo with your question and emailing it to service request at 99PI.org. And remember, the next time you're stuck in traffic and you are cursing the lights, know that somewhere there's an engineer who has spent years trying to steal back seconds on your behalf, one green light at a time. I'm Delaney Hall. Infrastructure is everywhere, and we are here to help you deal. decode it. Service request is a production of 99% Invisible and Campside Media. The show is produced in fact-checked by Julia K. Slavine and edited by Shoshi Shmulevitz. Mix by Iwin Lai Tramuan. Theme song and music by Swan Royale. Show arts by Aaron Nestor. Roman Mars is our boss at 99PI.
它是如何运作的？请提交你的服务请求，录制一条包含你问题的语音备忘录，并将其发电子邮件至 service request at 99PI.org。记住，下次你堵在路上对红绿灯破口大骂时，要知道某个地方正有一位工程师，花了数年时间试图为你争取回几秒钟的时间，一次一个绿灯。我是德兰尼·霍尔。基础设施无处不在，我们在此助你解读。Service Request 是 99% Invisible 和 Campside Media 联合制作的节目。本节目由朱莉娅·K·斯拉维恩（Julia K. Slavine）制作并核查事实，由肖希·什穆列维茨（Shoshi Shmulevitz）编辑。由艾文·莱·特拉姆安（Iwin Lai Tramuan）混音。主题曲和音乐由斯旺·罗亚尔（Swan Royale）创作。节目插图由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）制作。罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）是我们 99PI 的老板。
Kathy 2 is 99PI's executive producer. Matt Scher is the executive producer at Campside. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
凯茜·图（Kathy Tu）是 99PI 的执行制作人。马特·谢尔（Matt Scher）是 Campside 的执行制作人。我们是 SiriusXM 播客大家庭的一员。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。在 99PI.org 上有通往该服务器以及 99PI 每一期往期节目的链接。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。